- [Narrator] Fire
stations, big red trucks,
flashing sirens,
that cool shiny pole,
well, it all dates back to colonial times
and this guy had a little
something to do with it.
That's right.
Ben Franklin.
Most known for the Constitution,
electricity and the bifocals,
Ben Franklin had a weird
obsession with fire safety.
On a trip to Massachusetts,
Franklin noticed that
the good people of Boston
were much more fire savvy
than his fellow citizens in Philadelphia.
This got Ben thinking
and he came up with the idea
to create a club or society
of active men belonging
to each fire engine
whose business is to attend
all fires with it whenever they happen.
Then Ben got weird,
he wrote an anonymous letter
to his own newspaper
as a senior citizen titled,
‘Protections of Towns from Fire.’
“Dear Pennsylvania Gazette…”
The letter encouraged a
better fire safety plan
and painted a horrifying alternative.
People jumping out of windows,
breaking their necks
and being burned alive.
But it worked.
In 1736, the first American
volunteer fire department
was born.
The Union Fire Company.
It was comprised of 30 volunteers
and you might know some of them.
George Washington,
Thomas Jefferson,
and Samuel Adams.
That's right.
Our Founding Fathers
were also firefighters.
Soon after fire companies
and clubs sprang up all over Philadelphia
and then across the 13 colonies.
So, thanks to the matchless leadership
of Benjamin Franklin,
we now have firefighters.
Thanks, Ben.